[Music]
i think the history of women in
motorcycling is really interesting
because women have always been doing it
when i started the misfires i'd been
riding for a really long time but i
never saw women the minute that we put
the call out there were 10 girls and
then the next week there were 20 and you
know six months later there's 150 and
now there's over 250 across the united
states
we always joke that it was a thing that
we didn't know that we needed until we
had it and then we couldn't imagine life
without it i do have my own shop in new
york city which does custom motorcycle
seats and upholstery but i'm currently
run away with a circus with the wall of
death
the wall of death is
it's wild they're riding motorcycles
sideways on a vertical wall
samantha morgan was you know one of the
most famous 20th century wall riders
i work at the wall that she did ride at
there are very few industries where you
have men being inspired and following in
the footsteps of a woman not doing it
for a woman but because some lady blew
their minds
the wall of death is
living history
in 1916 the van buren sisters
motorcycled from brooklyn to san
francisco to prove that women could be
dispatched riders in world war one
they were even arrested several times
for wearing men's clothing illegal in
most states which really was just
protective gear and after all that the
army still rejected their applications
that history and the list of women over
the years that have done this is
important for me to keep going
the really cool thing is trying to
connect younger generation of riders to
an older generation of riders and so i'm
on my way to meet becky brown founder of
women in the wind
i first started riding motorcycles in
1976
but i didn't know one single woman who
wrote
so i actually put an ad in the local
newspapers and it it really blossomed
from there we now have 135 chapters of
women in the wind we have them as far
away as new zealand australia nepal
travel the road is absolutely freedom
to be able to hop on a motorcycle and
just go rain hail cold and heat that
bike gets me where i need to go whether
you're by yourself with a friend or with
a few people you would find adventure
partners
karina
i'm so glad you could make it
this is some of the girls from my toledo
chapter just some of them just some of
them
i think that knowing that they have a
family of other women to get together
and ride with it's wonderful women who
ride motorcycles are not afraid to do
anything
it's an adventure